would you like some ice cream first of
all very good job on the power of logic
[Applause]
it's hard to sing a song that's so
classic you know when you hear that song
you think of your voice no matter who
else sings it so it's an amazing thing
to get oh you were watching I'm really
glad I'm really happy I didn't know that
but did you write that song for back to
the future yeah sort of I mean when
Amblin entertainment has to have a
meeting with us and they said we've just
written this film and our lead character
Marty McFly his favorite band would be
Huey Lewis in the news so we thought how
would you like to write a song for the
film and I thought well great a
flattered I told him um flattered but
didn't necessarily know how to write for
film and I didn't fancy writing a song
called back to the future actually yeah
and they said no problem but they said
they just wanted one of your songs do
whatever you want and so the next thing
we wrote was power love but you are also
in Back to the Future you did a cameo
right sort of yeah they thought it would
be fun you know if we did it the kind of
as a uncredited disguise things right
yes and what a killer song oh my gosh
have you ever played in Cincinnati like
on the road mm-hmm not more than 30
times I was like that might be the
dumbest question I've ever asked an
artist yeah no he's a great job yeah we
played River Bend a bunch we played all
kinds of places yeah yeah I love all the
audience's being on the road there's
nothing like it and you get to live like
a teenager right you get to sleep till
noon somebody does your laundry and
catches up with you and you gain weight
so you're working on a Broadway musical
though in spite of like the hearing loss
and everything right well yeah we're
very excited we've been working on it
for about ten years we put it up in San
Diego at the Old Globe it's called the
heart of rock and roll and we've just
partnered with with Tony award-winning
producer Hunter Arnold who just produced
the hit a huge town yeah and we're gonna
bring it to Broadway next season
I do too I grew up in theater so I love
it you know what else is great is the
people right yeah they're so talented
yes
smart funny and generous and genuine
they're just great people to work with
yeah agreed agreed a lot of my friends
do you Broadway as well now but despite
your hearing loss though you still put
together the album right whether right
well all that stuff was cut before these
the two years ago there was all in the
cast only we were assembling we were
collecting and writing it took us you
know we're not very prolific we were
first of all we were doing 75 shows a
year yeah so you know that's busy with
traveling that's 120 shows yeah so we're
busy and we have lives and as I said
we're not really all that prolific so
and songs you know we're just hard to
write I mean there especially when
you're written a few of them and yeah
but when we we would get an idea we'd
record it and just put it in the can
they got theory being as long as we were
good in my band we were as good as we
ever were that we would just wait till
we had 10 songs released the record we
had seven songs my hearing collapsed we
waited it kind of a year to see if I
could recover no help so we thought
let's release them and share them with
the fans yeah earlier days of being with
Huey Lewis and the news like the whole
band like what do you remember from
those days in the beginning I remember
being booed off a lot of stages a lot of
the greats know our first tour we opened
for the Doobie Brothers and there who
were good friends and great people and
they really cared about us and we pretty
much got booed off every stay every
night we got so good we got so good at
going from song to song well you know
without any silence and so we at the end
of one song we hold the sustain and if
the guitar player had to switch for the
next song while we're holding the stage
which is a good talk
don't give those hecklers any moments we
are that's amazing that's horrible
who does that just drunk unlovable
people that's who does that like I mean
I had to listen to some people think
that are popular and and it's like one
of those things where I'm like booing
would be applicable but like it's like
but you don't do it that's rude
i I take it a funny story we were
playing with a dude brothers same thing
on that tour we're in San Antonio Texas
which is a big town yes for the doobies
alcohol I wrote China Grove and all that
and and now and I'd never been out in
the hall we're playing the big arena
whatever it is and I thought tonight I'm
just gonna go out and see what it's like
because you know the lights are down the
doobies are robbed nobody's gonna know
who I am I got a baseball hat and plus
we were just starting out and nobody
knew who we were anyway so I want the
very back row of the arena and sit down
and place was sold out
but in the very back row there were a
few seats empty because people had moved
up and my nearest guy was maybe where
that the end of that couch there's a guy
over there and it's dark and thing and
now I suddenly realizes the doobies are
playing oh they're at the spot where
they're gonna introduce themselves and
have that a hand for the opening act and
sure enough and I said well this will be
interesting and I sit there and they and
Pat Simmons goes well hi everybody you
know where the Doobie Brothers great to
have you here and how about a big hand
for our opening act tonight Huey Lewis
in the news and this guy right here goes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my I wanted to grab him
that is an unlikable human that's so
mean
you paid his money yeah you know what
I'd have been like still got your money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's a jerk we hate him okay subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going